hey Ann are you still nurse or did they
fire you because you slept with all the
doctors you want to try that again hey
Ann are you so nurse because Andy's not
feeling well What's Wrong Andy just got
a headache and I'm seeing double and I
got a song stuck in my head and my teeth
hurt also I'm hungry okay well some of
those things are symptoms and some of
them are just being a person did you hit
your head no oh yes technically I did
smash my head area into the wall area
yeah he was hanging up his gold record
oh my god are you okay yeah oh yeah
point is I have a gold record well I can
help you with cuts and bruises but the
other stuff you're gonna have to see a
real doctor hey smartass we can't afford
it hey smartass yes you can
you have insurance neither of your asses
are that smart because insurance is for
if something bad happens to your car PS
I haven't had it in years oh my god we
used to live together oh you still got
it for me
at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's famous chili the
trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot I'm serious about this
stuff I'm up the night before pressing
garlic and dicing whole Tomatoes i toast
my own ancho chiles it's a recipe passed
down from Malone's for generations it's
probably the thing I do best Charles
Boyle he's a grinder not the most
brilliant detective but he works harder
than anyone else he's not physically
here on can I ask you kind of an
important question you know like when
you go to the ATM and you get money is
there an actual guy standing behind the
wall who slides dollar bills in there
no yeah this robots Oh actually you know
what I do have a serious question in a
movie predator can you rub any kind of
mud on yourself
to prevent predator from seeing you with
this thermal heat signature site or is
it oh that sucks
are you hurt no all good all good
oops except for my mouth oh whoa
five-second rule
nope ah come on we'd better get you to a
dentist did you see that see what yes
you're right to stop it thank you
dejected you let Michael fall in play it
again lean away and let you fall man I
think when I started to see you go in I
think I just froze
I don't think you froze my friend we
have a bathroom pet his name is Horace
and he's either a small rat or a large
cockroach and he's either sleeping or
dead here's the schedule eight hours
both on watch eight hours I sleep you
watch eight hours you sleep i watch I
set an alarm I made the perfect ringtone
listen all right we got binocs camera
night-vision goggles computer and baby
basketball oh my god I love that my
whole problem with basketball was big
ball tiny hands tiny ball problem solved
OOP me ready ooping one two three
look guys cause I felt how cool did it
feel so um
and II jumped over this fence he was
crossing through to get home and then he
fell right there oh my god
how did we let this happen dream with me
for a second am doesn't this
neighborhood deserve a first-class Park
imagine a shiny new playground with
jungle gym and swings pool tennis courts
volleyball courts racquetball courts
basketball court regulation football
field we could put an amphitheater over
there with Shakespeare in the Park it's
really not that big of a pit could do
some of those things it's gonna take a
little extra work but why not try I
think that would be great
me too I'm going in
why don't worry I have a card add-on
that I could see that but yeah April
document this okay why are you any
fact-finding mission is to get right
into the battle zone you know it's like
George Bush when he flew over New
Orleans or Richard Nixon when he went to
China see what the Chinese we're up to
no are you okay Leslie
hold on April's gonna get some photos
for the website you just be still don't
move around as much hey you guys I
thought of a funny response at Terry's
text from earlier which might take my
look for hit Send Charles you've trained
for this moment okay we trust you just
send it come here good job all right I'm
gonna do it
why did it go look to the left alright
whatever are you the kind of doctor he
gets hooked on his own drugs I bet you
are so Andy tell me what happened I was
reading an encyclopedia and I tripped or
fell over and hit my head or brain
helmet you call it yeah he sneezed and
smacked his head against the wall yeah
that sounds about right well if it's a
concussion it's extremely mild so I
wouldn't worry about it anything else
bothering it nope yeah well I mean yeah
I've got a weird rash in my knee pit
area and my tongue on this side doesn't
taste anything anymore sometimes when I
walk my ankles make like a weird
rattlesnake sound what else things that
are far away from my eyes are fuzzy I
once ate a Twix with the wrapper on it
and I've never seen the wrapper come out
also I've swallowed every piece of gum
that I've chewed for the past 25 years
I don't know broke my thumb when the way
over here it just fix me well I can help
you with the thumb I don't have to give
you referrals for specialists for the
other thousand things Wow
thanks for nothing dr. Harris you're
welcome okay well I did not get the job
in New York but I got the real prize
domestic bliss Jan made me breakfast
this morning well she bought the milk
it's soy this is why I do it that's what
I have to come home to she probably
won't be up for a few hours this is
going to be a very good year very good
Jan is at home Jim is back my protege
Ryan is a corporate good stuff
Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales
team I feel very blessed
[Music]
heads up
there's our perp looking all her pee
just perp in his way down perp street
take a picture get one second this
lights really unflattering for his
complexion it doesn't have to be perfect
Tom Olsen is a bad dude he's held up for
electronic stores at gunpoint and I wish
you hadn't read that Annie Leibowitz
book we're calling it a book was a
visual journey you're probably think I
should shoot this income instead of lack
of light yes shoot color why have you
been shooting black and white where's he
going now
damnit NYPD freak
[Music]
you strapped
our foot chase my birthday wish finally
came through
[Applause]
we're gonna hurt yourself
mic stand clear Mike get off of the lift
I I'm fine muga would you look we'll get
somebody to clean that little ones that
gotta clean that up we have to have the
same service Oh
let's get you home and get me some ice
cream here's your bill
oh yeah we'll be needing that I've got
the free medicine card there's a $500
deductible for dental procedures oh I
think you're wrong we have the insurance
thing I believe recovered it's still
$500 Oh
because you know what Dinah's ash
you